[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan Leaf covers college football and uh
NFL analyst for Westwood One also
contributes to good morning football the
former number two overall pick in the
NFL draft in 1998 joining us on the
program if you were playing today the
edge rusher that would make you the most
nervous would be who Max Crosby just
plain and simple the motor that guy has
he never comes off the field he never
stops in the running game chasing guys
down getting after the quarterback
always just like a little gnat you know
poking and prodding and making things
worse out on the football field I love
him I have a little you know soft spot
in my heart for Him uh because of what
he's been through and how he's come out
of it and it's just I love I love
watching that that young man compete uh
and he's my favorite defensive player as
an edge rusher out there right now why
don't we focus on hurries or pressures
more than sacks because I think I could
get eight
pressures I could get one sack yeah I
want my guy in the back field always
reminding you you better hurry up you
better make a decision not just the one
sack it feel well as a former
quarterback would you be more concerned
about eight pressures or a guy with one
sack well the thing about it is is that
anytime you're working with your
offensive lineman uh sacks are a huge
statistic in terms of what goes uh on
their Collective resume as a as a unit
it's like if you were to you know you
know step out of bounds a half a yard
behind the line of scrimmage uh they
would absolutely undress you in film on
Monday because that cost us a sack Leaf
you know mentality so sacks are an
important number for players out there
but you're exactly right I mean if if
you can live in the back field
statistics are such a huge part of
winning these Awards like oh he had you
know 27 sacks or something like that or
or that's the reason he was Defensive
Player of the Year there are a lot of
players that are presenting a lot of
problems for offensive linemen and
offensive schemers this year that aren't
necessarily getting guys on the ground
in the back field but are there every
single play why is scoring down in the
NFL I think it's the CBA I do I think it
is the limitation of
practices uh uh preseason games all the
things that go into it I just think
we've had a real slowdown what I do
think over the N last uh what nine weeks
of the Season or so I think we're going
to see an uptick and I think we're
goingon to start seeing some more points
scored more offensive um uh um um
performances and some better quarterback
play from the elite guys moving forward
yeah but we've had over 60 quarterbacks
attempt to pass and we're nine weeks in
Ryan that's the injury part of it and
also I also think that has a big thing
to do with the CBA
uh that was uh changed in terms of these
soft tissue injuries I mean guys are
just getting banged up more and more
because I don't think they're used to
getting hit my wife and I were watching
the game last night and we saw a guy's
helmet uh I think it was Tyson bent's
when he hit the ground it just how much
it moved the guys don't they don't lock
it up like I I looked at my wife I said
that thing on me was like such locked up
like you could shake my face mask like
that my head wasn't moving inside it
these guys helmets just pop off like
nothing anymore they don't wear pads any
they got the pants up above their knees
I mean these there's it doesn't surprise
me that guys are banged up and now
quarterbacks the backups in particular
are gonna have to step up and play I'm
trying to figure out Bryce young and I
I'm curious what would be your line of
demarcation of now is when I know who
he's going to be because if I'm going to
use the same reference points uh
analogies then I have to do it with CJ
strad so if I'm if I'm comfortable with
CJ Stroud's going to be a star am I
comfortable in saying Bryce young is not
going to be
star I I don't think so I mean also we
are pretty much a prisoner of the moment
when it comes to the NFL from week to
week because you know just what was it
just over 10 days ago CJ strout was
being beaten by Bryce young right and
then what CJ stren goes out and does
last week in terms of breaking the
record 470 yards five touchdown passes
and with that big comeback win the jux
to position is so drastic and so
everybody can mount and jump on top of
Bryce young then he does go doesn't have
a great game last night you know he
doesn't turn it over but still not not a
great game after what he how he
performed against the Colts I want to
see more I you know I lay this at the
feet of Frank Reich a little bit Josh
McDaniels just got fired from his second
job maybe Frank Reich is not a head
coach what he was able to do in
Indianapolis just was never to meet
expectations maybe that's the case and
that's not a bad thing you know great
coordinators don't necessarily need to
turn out to be great head coaches and un
fortunately we've see that happen from
time to time but I want to see a full
year in this offense the size thing for
me was always an issue the offense has
to be catered to him much more
differently he has to have easy throws
ones he can identify and they need to
use motion they're just not using the
motion to allow things to space out and
give him more of an opportunity and so I
think they're doing him a disservice
there as well talking to Ryan Leaf
College analyst also NFL analyst with
Westwood one and good morning football
I'm going to give you over unders the
rest of the year for win totals Panthers
over under three and a half under
Cardinals over under three and a half
over Bears five and a
half Justin Fields comes back is healthy
looks like he did those last two games
before the Minnesota
debacle I'm still going to go under five
and a half okay are you still all in on
Justin Fields if they end up with the
number one number two pick in the draft
well uh that's what I want these last
games to be I want I I I am I I do think
he is a I think he's better than uh
Caleb Williams I think he's better than
Drake May uh he may argue the Michael
penck conversation but I don't think
cold weather for Michael is necessarily
going to be the best thing for him I
don't know I there's a lot to go there
but I I do think he is a uh a an
incredibly athlete and a quarterback
that is starting to develop those I know
just so understand let's say you're the
Bears GM and you have the number one
pick in the draft I'm going to go get
Marvin Harrison
Jr I know it's a wide receiver but you
need you need you add that with DJ Moore
I think that's a problem and you think
that Justin Fields is better than Caleb
Williams yeah and I'd use that fifth
year option to to find that out I I do
think the quarterback no no you have to
know Ryan you can't find it out you got
to extend him and you're passing on you
have you have to find find out over the
last weeks of the season this year you I
mean you you have to have your answer
Ryan poles already made that decision
last year when he said no we're gonna
trade it away we're gonna go with Justin
I don't know how much more you found out
the games against Denver and Washington
if those are just outliers then you
probably do but those for me are
identifiers that's what he can be I just
don't know if Matt eberl is going to be
the head coach I don't think he's going
to be and so that there you have it if
you're gonna if you're going to break up
the band if you're going to send another
coaching staff and figure something else
out I would probably suggest and think
that they would go with a new
quarterback as well all right over under
Patriots five and a half under giants
three and a half under Broncos six and a
half oh that's a lot what they got eight
games left nine games left I think I'm
gonna go under with that those are a lot
those are teams that aren't going to be
around for the playoffs so they're not
they're not going to be the teams that
you know have chances to win those games
down the stretch all right um what do
you think should what do you think will
happen to Jim Harbaugh in
Michigan um I I maybe I'm I don't know
what I've been doing with this I I
haven't I haven't really looked into it
like how much of it is real and how much
of it is not I just I I haven't cared
and I don't know if that's a more of a
slight on me than it is uh on my
attention to college football right now
I just sign stealing doesn't bother you
no the way they did it I think I've said
this before I think it's just they were
clever more clever they worked harder uh
they had a plan in place I will say this
Jim Harbaugh of course was my backup
quarterback in San Diego my uh my my
second and third year and I've never
been around a guy that's more
competitive than than Jim Harbaugh more
competitive he would he would want to
win at every single thing so it doesn't
surprise me that if this is true that
there was this elaborate sign stealing
scheme that that exists Ed because that
dude wants to win at everything give me
an example of what it was he annoying to
be
around you know what he wasn't because
I'm I was I was rather annoying as a
competitive guy my whole life uh I had
to win to at everything and and I had a
bad attitude when I when I would lose
you know and so him and I kind of got
along and what was funny was when we
were competing my third year when they
had brought him in and I was hurt my
whole second year they let us fight it
out to be the starter again because no
one expected me to be the starter again
in year three and we went and competed
like crazy and in that Atlanta game the
third preseason game I started nine for
n with a touchdown pass and I remember
after that game sitting in the locker
next to him he's like he looked at me
and he's like we went to war we competed
you won and then he just he just put his
hand behind my back and started coaching
me up and supported me he taught me how
to be a professional by the time I had
blown it all in San Diego when I got
down to Tampa in Dallas I was an actual
teammate and a professional I just
wasn't as talented I had hurt my wrist I
wasn't the guy to be a starter anymore
but I knew had to be a professional
quarterback and I owe that to Jim
Harbaugh and the support and the
competition he gave me to try to win
that job uh in year three I'm goingon to
guess your social lives would have been
different in San Diego you and Harbaugh
yeah they were pretty different but you
know that second year I you know I kind
of I fell into a relationship with which
I thought was going to solve everything
was to to uh to date and to marry the
most uh beautiful and uh popular uh
former charger cheerleader everybody
would love Ryan Leaf right they love her
you know instead they looked at her like
what is wrong with that woman she must
be nuts to go and be with that guy so
that backfired on me too so I was pretty
much a home buddy by that time you know
my rookie year was where I was like you
know Playboy Mansion you know all over
the place and stuff like that by year
two and three when harau showed up I was
I was pretty settled down what happened
at the Playboy
Mansion uh a lot of great
things can you can you be vague with me
um well the the the parties where uh
where they where where the women came
painted you know when they they went
through the whole process of painting on
the outfits were we at the Playboy
Mansion at the same time we may have
been I don't know I I went there on on a
paint
night and uh I just remember the Dom
triplets were
there so all I remember and uh yeah we
we might have been there um I was there
I was I was there three separate times
and uh um you know they're fond memories
that's all that's all I can say about I
mean I was 20 22 years old I somehow was
given millions of
dollars I don't think I was very
handsome but the millions of dollars
made me seem more handsome I think in a
lot of sense but anyway they'll be
they'll be memorable times for me to
remember especially with you here Dan on
the
show uh I remember Drew krey was there
and and salami from the white
shadow um oh I remember uh oh what
Paulie Shore Paulie Shore was there I
think he was always there wasn't he yeah
he may have lived there he may lived
like in the cages with the peacocks and
stuff outside the gr U but uh I was just
really in awe the kid from Montana the
the redneck hick from Montana was just
kind of like like is this real and I had
two my boys with me who came from
Montana too like the original Entourage
feel to it and we were just I mean we
were just in awe you know we show up on
the Sunset Strip and go to the Sky Bar
and Dublin's and it was just like I mean
you know I should have I should have
should have known that like I wasn't
long for the spotlight when I was just
like this is crazy fun good stuff let's
go uh great to talk to you as always
have a great weekend my best to your
wife and uh we'll talk to you soon you
bet good to see you sorry I couldn't be
there in person we'll see you next time
yep another meet Friday we'll wait for
you Ryan Leaf college football NFL
analyst for Westwood One also NFL
Network he was on good morning football